hey y'all time for another movie
retrospective that's right getting a
bunch of mile away yeah we're actually
filming a couple of these at the same
same time yeah yeah this one we're doing
okay so we did the first creep show
which came out in 1982 we did a review
of that so if you want to go check that
out you can on the list for a long time
one eight two yeah we're trying so we're
trying to get these out of the way so
creep show 2 is actually on shudder at
the moment also and I had seen this a
zillion times when I was growing up not
a bad movie I actually saw this in the
theater when I first came out in 1987 so
yeah well I saw the first one but
looking over the back of the damn wall
the drive I watched it from the back of
my house I think this chanson massacre
there's nothing in there no scanners I
saw scanners at the drive-in IRA part
two wasn't that bad it's not as good as
part one well okay but it's it's a
decent movie
now I'm gonna I mean the original
Creepshow from 1982 is really as only
one of my favorite 80s horror movies
it's so fun it's like you know we did a
review of it before it's just the look
of it is so cool the stories are good
all the animation it's funny it's like
really cool looking own it's a comic
book movie yeah yeah so part two um you
know like a lot of sequels that kind of
suffers because the first one was so
good and so iconic
this one came out you know five years
later it was actually still the
screenplay was still written by George
Romero and they were still based on
Stephen King stories but you could tell
that this was kind of a cut rate to hurt
more like budget version of the first
one it didn't it didn't have that same
epic feel of the first one yeah with you
know what I mean that the animated
breaks in between the set up and the
wrap around that wrap around was tight
on the first one yeah well I'm the first
one - it wasn't animated it was
live-action yeah the second one it was
animated and I really think that that
was a mistake I know that they were
probably trying to make it seem more
like a comic book movie or seem like
that but the thing that I liked about
the first one was that
live-action wraparound you know was a
good story in its own right and I also
liked that the you know the little
skeleton character which they called the
creep and the second one he doesn't talk
he just like his kind of lurking outside
the window and he's all scary and stuff
and then it kind of goes into animation
for the for the credits or whatever s'en
wasn't animated it just looked animated
because of all those damn candy colors
they had on everything during there
right yeah yes and they had like some
like swords like that looked like panels
in betweens that's what I was talking
about it yeah yeah the second one you
know all the interstitials like the
wraparound story was actually like a
cartoon yeah and they made the the creep
kind of a character that talked and like
introduced the stories and made pawns
like the Cryptkeeper and stuff like that
and I really you know it had a little
bit of a story to it that was similar to
the first one like a little revenge
story just like you know that you see
comics but I think it didn't hold up as
well now the thing about this one like I
said it was still based on three Stephen
King stories it was an originally
supposed to be five just like the first
one but because I guess they thought it
would cost too much to make it two of
the stories got cut now two of the
stories that got cut there was one that
was called pinfall which I've read a
summary of it and I don't know if the
summary was just badly written or
something like that but I have no
[ __ ] idea what there's [ __ ] like
what it was supposed to be about but the
other story that was cut was capped from
how now that story was actually made
later as part of another anthology movie
called tales from the dark side
yeah which was that was a good one which
yeah which some people actually kind of
see is like the spiritual please show -
or the spiritual rape show three because
it still is it has like the same vibe
we'll probably do a review of that on at
some point too because I really really
liked Harry's in it as a witch I kind of
forgive him for this I mean yeah I
remember what it was like back then
mm-hmm we were young blockbuster videos
and video rentals was now just like a
new thing
everybody had VCRs and out of the blue
there was a huge demand for [ __ ]
or movies yeah that's what we did on the
weekend we went down he said rented a
bunch of movies and went back and
watched him with all our friends because
we weren't old enough got the clubs yet
yeah so the Hollywood and the and the
independent film scene was doing
everything they could to bring things to
market quickly as possible they didn't
really they weren't really worrying
about the theater release that much they
were I think they were mostly worried
about how much were they gonna sell this
[ __ ] the blockbuster for well
particularly in regards to horror movies
it's just yes definitely yeah because
that's something that like you said like
a lot of teenagers every week when we
were like what's out this weekend what's
out this week and we were looking for a
new one
yeah and there had to be at least one
new it movie yeah I mean like you know
man all this new or movie it's like
Herbert West or it's like this when it's
like that one you know I mean then
that's that's what the scene was like
back then when you were a teenager yeah
they were they were just trying to get
product to us I think we just quickly as
they could it well it's weird to me too
though that and we really didn't care
yeah if it was slightly inferior it
really didn't matter well you know I
mean we were still having fun at the
time we were sneaking booze watching and
watching these things though you know
well hell I willingly watched sorority
babes at the slimeball bowl-o-rama on
shudder the other day we loved them all
back there which is stupid as hell but
still kind of fun and we weren't reading
into them as much as a modern adult
reviewer would read into them yeah I
think maybe weren't as picky we weren't
as picky back then I guess not because
some of the movies that I really enjoyed
back then cuz I loved it like all this
horror my reason I just like even the
stupid ones I'd be like yeah awesome my
brother used to love that [ __ ] and like
I watch them now and some of them are
still super fun so but some of them I'm
like wow this is really boring murdered
what why did I like this no internet and
the video games weren't that good there
wasn't much choice and you weren't old
enough to go out to the club it was
better it was all better than what was
on TV true yeah the thing about
Creepshow too like I said it's strange
if they were trying to get it to market
that quickly they took long enough
because the original Creepshow came out
in 19
- and was like kind of a big success I
feel like and then but this one didn't
come out for like five years after that
it seems like too late yeah like well I
think the production of this was kind of
sideways it does seem like that because
it was all it seemed like it had a lot
of trouble like Kenya - I think they
were just like lucky to get this one
babe
yeah and in a way I kind of feel like I
mean it probably would have been good I
mean I don't know I really like the cat
from hell sequence that they filmed for
tales from the dark side the movie so if
they put that one and the other batshit
crazy one that I can't figure out what
it supposed to be about if they'd put
that in that in this one it might have
been something cuz to me what even when
I went cuz like I said I saw this in the
theater it just seemed like I'm like
only three stories it's like that's
really it was not as good as it was not
as good as the first one like it wasn't
a disaster no it's a it's not bad it was
not that it was pretty good and it was
what was really good at was video-rental
yeah I mean you know I mean when this
thing came out he rented it you know
what's really weird about this okay so I
saw this in the theater and I saw it a
bunch of times on home video and then I
didn't see it for many years probably
15-20 years and then we watched it again
a couple weeks ago on shutter yeah and
do you know what strange is that I could
have sworn cuz his three stories the
three stories are old cheap wooden head
the raft and the hitchhiker
yeah I could have sworn I would have bet
a substantial amount of money that the
raft was the first story but it's not it
had it hidden like did they switch him
or am I just high I hadn't seen it in so
long I thought the raft was a movie unto
itself I thought there was a Stephen
King movie called the raft maybe I
forgot that it was on a compilation yeah
cuz I remember seeing it they remember I
didn't know I forgot that it was all in
this movie remember thinking about that
scene you know I mean with cuz I read
the book ii don't think was on
monkeyshines that little short story
monkey [ __ ] yeah it was it or whatever
that I call monkey I know it's not was a
compilation of Stevie a short stories
and I thought there was a full-length
film but I cuz I remembered those scenes
but then when we saw it on shudder
it took me back you know I mean I was
like oh yeah that's right I forgot it
was on this one yeah the raft was
actually the only story in it that I had
read this short story of it previously
the other two I don't think they were
standalone short stories before then I
think they were just written originally
for this yeah mistake I didn't read them
in because I don't remember reading the
other ones unless they were in some
couple and I read most of his [ __ ]
that read the night shift and whatever
the [ __ ] the other read a lot with that
monkey with the symbols on the front I
must say that I kind of got a soft spot
for Stephen King short stories I do as
well
they're very good because he just gets
to the point and you know they're
they're not very long and you're like it
was pretty cool story
like the jot the guy yeah you do travel
across space-time and [ __ ] you had to be
knocked out in order to do it if you
were awake it felt like it took a
billion years so when you emerged on the
other end you were insane that was a
good one and that was like maybe tanky
and said you know what and now that I'm
thinking about just speaking of Stephen
King short stories you know what another
anthology movie we should do is cat's
eye I don't think I remember that one oh
yeah when you were seven quitters
incorporated with the guy that was quit
smoking and they made him Walker air
they made him walk her in the building I
don't think I remember that one no no
that wasn't I do remember the one thing
I just forgot the name of it you once
said it was probably a spiritual
successor to the dark terrace my dark
side that's right yeah we gotta do that
one too yeah oh that's out like I said
that doesn't really have anything much
to do with Stephen King's and nobody cat
from hell
it was a no no cats I had um that might
have been three or four stories it had
quitters incorporated which had James
Woods in it he was trying to quit
smoking and he went to this place and
they're like everybody's watching him
and like if you if you sneak a cigarette
they'll like cut off your waist finger
or something like that and then there's
one called the ledge which is what I was
getting confused where the there was a
mobster and he makes the guy like walk
around the building like way up on the
[ __ ] skyscraper and then there's one
with Drew Barrymore and there's like a
little demon or something like running
around it it's good memory I don't
remember that one you remember cat's eye
we're definitely have to do that you see
all right so Creepshow to starts out
even though like I said I was Chris
Warren and would have bet you $50 that
the raft was the first story but it's
not it's a lot wouldn't have this the
first story
yeah but about the dad wouldn't Indiana
yeah it was like so it's
really old couple and they own this like
a general store in this like nowhere
town out in the middle of butt-fuck
Wyoming or where it's near an Indian
Reservation yeah so you know have how
they consistent well I guess they're not
but I was gonna say how they can sustain
a whole general storm like there's like
two people in this but a bit of highway
going out in front of it I guess yeah
but yeah so they're falling on hard the
whole town's fall on hard times
obviously cuz like I said there's maybe
about five buildings in this whole place
yeah and so some robbers coming well the
Native American tribe comes first and
they're like apparently they've been
buying some stuff on credit and they
feel really bad about it so they go so
should they go to the old people and
they're like here take art this is our
tribes like tribe our jewelry jewelry
like all of our expensive stuff please
hold on to it like until we compare it
right cuz cuz it's not cool that we owe
you all this money and all this other
stuff so then yeah I can't do that yeah
and he doesn't want to take it but the
guy makes him take it so I think his
name - white moon yeah now white moon
has this nephew who is a complete blaze
douchebag Tate yeah heavy metal
douchebag yeah he has like this really
long he kind of looked a little bit like
Ian Astbury yeah in the day back in the
day it was a big beautiful Lobby was
pretty chair like he's pretty and yeah
so he wanted to look you're moving
around I can dig all blurry okay
he wants to go to Hollywood because he
thinks the minute that everyone sees his
hair that they're just gonna put him in
all the movies ever forever it's a good
story and so he so he needs to steal
some money to get the hell out of this
nowhere but whole town and go to
Hollywood where he's immediately gonna
get discovered because of his beautiful
hair he's got a sidekick who was
familiar sonica it's that dude that
wasn't a dude that play it from alien
from aliens wasn't it I have no I don't
know for the guy who played corporal
Hicks nah couple Hicks I thought no that
I thought one of his henchmen was ended
up being famous in another movie
could've swore ah okay I'm thinking
about more I saw that one of his
henchmen is low mass that dude I thought
it was a different aliens but I didn't
know I could have said was like one of
his he has two henchmen and they come in
and one of the henchmen is named fatso
or fat stuff okay
wikipedia says fat stuff but I coulda
sworn he was just saying fat so I'm like
is that his name but I guess it is
that's just what they keep telling I'm
like okay well that's that's what his
parents name to visit easy pop death I
thought one of the fatso
I thought one of his henchmen was a guy
who ended up being famous but I don't
think so like I can't remember at the
moment like what even looks like I
remember the fat guy because I just
remember him in there like eating all
the snacks I thought one of the Hitchin
was a guy that played Hudson and yeah
it's been several weeks since we've seen
this but okay but yeah so so they go in
there to rob to rob the place and they
actually want to get the tribe's jewelry
back but the whole guy doesn't wanna
give it to them so they're like you know
threatening the wife and everything and
then the old guy tries to be a hero the
wife gets shot then they'll get shot so
they both get shot now through this
whole thing old the titular old cheap
wooden head who was this you know one of
those very atypical stereo like you know
Indians out in front of these general
stores in Chile yeah yeah holds the
cigars yeah although he didn't have a
cigar did he have some didn't have a cup
in his hand or something it wasn't I
thought it was like a I don't remember
what it was yeah it was I thought it was
like a bunch of arrows but I can't right
yeah well they come and they do all this
suck and big dishonor and the Native
American Indian magic [ __ ] brings this
thing to life in this this wooden Indian
goes after him for revenge yes he put
some like Indians yeah yeah and he goes
after it worse it's solid wood it's
[ __ ] indestructible yeah and he's
like walking like a Ray Harryhausen
Native American Terminator one yeah but
she just made of what although I thought
you know it's like this this
kind of story it's it's kind of cheesy
but it's sort of like upset me I guess
the world tale well just be good well
all of them are I mean all the whole
point of EC Comics was pretty much all
of them were straight-up revenge stories
um and usually and this this story was
kind of an exception but usually none of
the characters were all that good or all
that likable they were all like kind of
morally graves like they were all out to
bad [ __ ] and they just everybody kind of
got their just desserts in the end but
this one actually the old couple had you
know we're super sweet and super nice
and they'd ever never did anything but
they got gunned down in cold blood
defending the Indian jewels yeah
defending the tribal jewels because they
wouldn't give them up to this to this
nephew Indian spirits [ __ ] weird out
there and whip that ass after that yeah
and so spoiler alert because the one the
nephew Sam made such a big deal about
how beautiful his hair was and stuff
like that so old chief wouldn't end must
have heard that [ __ ] because Gavin
because I was like I well you know it's
coming because like the whole and so
even even as a kid I saw this when I was
what 15 years old I guess I was 15 when
this came out because I saw the theater
knew that [ __ ] was coming and yeah it's
like as soon as he started going on and
out about his hair he get he goes into
like photo booth and he's like taking
pictures of himself like looking all
foxy and everything and I'm like oh
that'd be like a singer from the coat he
did yeah I was like that [ __ ] is gonna
get scalped and I was not disappointed
second one of course is by a bunch of
teenagers taking their [ __ ] muscle
cars down to the lake and they get up on
this big raft that's out there the
middle of the lake they're grab-assing
around with these you know eighties
girls and of course there's some kind of
toxic sludge on top of the toxic sludge
monster [ __ ] yeah floating on top of the
water basically like a really big killer
a hefty bag yeah and it gets underneath
the raft and if you jump off that raft
it dissolves you and this thing's
reaching up through the cracks and
grabbing people pulling them down and it
is bad it's just like it was in the book
yeah it is very I mean it's a very very
simple story it's basically just kind of
these 14 years they go to this
know where it's offseason I guess so
there's no one around yeah that's great
and if it car doors open I'm on one of
the on the on the Trans Am they left the
damn cars at the car doors up with a
radio blast so they could hear the
Whitesnake you hear what this snake
whatever they're metal why it's hair
metal but rot yeah yeah and they're sit
there water do you think we can make you
think we can swim across and of course
this thing's already killed the
good-looking girls last long no and it
got down to where that last guy said
bucket and why it was even one dude he
jumped across no while it was eating the
girl girl yeah well you know dude girl
whatever that was eating hurry he took a
cross he admitted he made a break for it
to swim across the top of leg and he did
make it but he didn't roll away fast
enough and that [ __ ] came like a wave
and got it up on the BC I feel like this
whole story could have been avoided by
one just staying in and playing video
games and do what dude is [ __ ] talk
[ __ ] yeah I made it yeah yeah well like
like I said so many poor decisions and
and and I know that that's you know
that's kind of a thing with a lot of
horror movies so many poor decisions
okay one this water is like cold enough
to cause cardiac arrest and yet we're
still going there anyway there's no one
else around we'll leave the car running
so the battery will be sure to be dead
when we get back that'll be cool they
get there pretty much within two minutes
after they get to the raft actually
before they get to the raft I think they
see the weird thing floating through the
water and they get up on there this
monster comes and then one of the girls
I think kind of falls in right away and
gets eaten so they know like what
they're dealing with right away now the
other guy that gets killed like this
sort of like douchey like jock dude yeah
um I I always remember him getting
killed because he could basically get
sucked in between the cracks the crack
and his and his leg is like go like that
going like that crack wrong to you know
gonna dissolve you pull your skin off
your skeleton and [ __ ] it was pretty bad
well and here's the thing though it's
like so the one guy and now I'm the blob
the one guy and the one girl are left
over yeah and I think this the girl that
was left was
I think was the other guy it was the
dead guys girlfriend maybe I don't
remember from the short story you know a
lot of it had to do with teenage lust
you know they were checking out these
girls pretty bad you know they're
[ __ ] looking at they're looking at
the asses and all and talking [ __ ] you
know I mean they were less he even tried
to dry-hump that girl why the monster
well that's what I was just gonna say
because so so two of the people are dead
so they've seen what this monster can do
right this oil slick monster so they
fall asleep they get a few hours of
shut-eye that boot wakes up first she's
laying on the raft and while she's
asleep he's like I'm gonna get I'm gonna
grope that yeah while she's sleeping
yeah and he was like a nerd and I think
it was a virgin he had never baby but
I'm like this they were all teenagers
and [ __ ] yeah that's what I'm saying
about poor decision so he starts like
making out with her instead of like
trying to figure out a way to get them
both off their masters and then it wreck
bratty half of her face and ripped her
face off while he's there trying to feel
her titties so yeah special and then
while she was getting eaten he's like oh
well here's my chance and it made sense
back in the day that back in the day you
know came up amongst teenagers you were
likely to get killed come in there
Freddie would come in you know what
that's perfect that's what yeah true
that's all like I said the minute you
hormones man hormones in minutes you got
your panties taking off yeah like
someone was getting a machete through
the floor it was back then
now the third story is good I think this
is the best one it does swing man worthy
of the first movie yes I think so too I
liked all the stories it's just that
this one kind of had it I had kind of a
humorous angle to it and go to it that
was present in the first movies I think
that if this had been in the first one I
don't think anyone would have complained
no I think this is easily the best story
and and I think it's basically down to
like you said the dark humor I think
it's down to the acting too because yeah
the woman that plays rich [ __ ] runs
over black dude the character well no
she's so she's like cheating on her
husband this is again like I said about
a lot of the characters being morally
gray and then what's like it's tough
even though like and shitty stuff
happens to them so she's like hired some
gigolo
or something well he is a gigolo isn't
he because she pays him yeah so she's
humping some guy and then she's like oh
[ __ ] I gotta get home for my husband
gets home she doesn't find out that I'm
humping a gigolo and she was a gold
digger yes so while she's driving home
she well I think at first she blows past
like a hitchhiker because it's like oh
it's a black man and also the kilos on
he had it yeah he had a sign he was
going to Dover
Friday um so she blows past him but then
later on she ends up choosing her BMW
yes later on she ends up hitting him or
or someone else hits him or something
like that does she hit him I mean I know
she leaves him wounded on the road
that's right yeah um so so the
hitchhiker spends the rest of this story
like she hit him kind of yeah kind of
like trying to take revenge on this
woman so it's like so he's kind of
basically zombified and he's like coming
back trying to get her and I'm she
passes him she passes him again he's out
again and she hits him in it is pretty
cool oh the best part of this don't walk
can't read get rid of him he's hanging
on the side of the car like I said I
think what makes this good others in the
gore which is awesome and she keeps
running over the stood and it's kind of
like it's sick but it's also really
funny yeah
but she's good in it because she has
this kind of like monologue going
because she talks to herself
which I do too um so she's in her car
like talking to herself like trying to
sort everything out and it's just funny
because it's like really relatable but
also she's really like sarcastic and
snarky and stuff and it's really funny
so and she's in this like unbelievable
situation and she's just kind of like
what the [ __ ] she keeps hitting the same
dude and then leaving him in the dust
and then she hits him again he's up at
Frodo he keeps I think the best part of
it is when she runs him into the tree
yeah and then she keeps backing up and
hitting him and back and I've been
hitting him and then it's like all his
little like little eyeballs like hanging
up on stalks and chilling and [ __ ] like
that and so after a while like she keeps
hitting him and hitting the tree and
hitting the trees be like died yeah and
then she's either knocked out or shieff
I guess she's now
doubt she hits her head on the on the
steering wheel or something and then she
wakes up later on and the guy's gone and
there's no blood or anything like that
so she thinks it was all a dream so
she's like oh thank heavens I just hit a
tree or whatever and then she goes home
and she's like sitting in her garage and
like the husband's coming home and stuff
I think it's all over the so he gets
killed yeah now so those are the three
main stories like I said there were two
other ones you know that one of them was
film for sale so the dark side the other
was never filmed I feel like the other
story was somebody on Kickstarter tried
to raise money to film it and I think
they got enough money but I'm not sure
if they ever filmed it like I said it
did it didn't really sound like it
sounded like two rival bowling teams and
then they were zombified or so I don't
really get it but um whatever but um we
didn't talk about the animated yeah wrap
wrap wrap around which much like the
first one it was like a little kid who
was into the Creepshow magazine but was
being picked on now and the first one he
was being picked on by his dad so he
took revenge on his dad and this one he
was being picked on by bullies so what
he does is he orders this Venus flytrap
from an ad in the back of the Creepshow
magazine yeah and so it so between each
of the things there's little things of
him like being chased by the bullies
there's him picking up the package of
the of the plant and then like in the
last one when he's being chased by the
bullies that you can see that's just
like Little Shop of Horrors you know the
Venus fliers have grown like really big
and they eat all the bullies so there's
that so I think there's a bit in the
beginning before it goes animated
because I think it's live-action for a
second and I think that the creep who is
throwing the Creepshow magazines out of
the back of the truck I'm pretty sure
that's Tom Savini
but the mask that they made him wear is
so bad it's it's just like Sub Spencer's
level right and I'm just like lon it's a
it's like that's Tom Savini he could
have done it
why did they even put a mask on him at
all is what I'd like to know why
couldn't he just be Tom Savini and he
could just be just like what for what it
was it's not it's not as good as the
first well like I said it's a decent
movie is still I think yeah you know it
was what it was it was it was a movie of
the time now I have heard the market of
that day like I said tales from the dark
side is generally considered you know
like a spiritual sequel to this movie
it's very much it is it is actually very
good it's in a similar kind of vein now
I should note they had a whole TV
batteries to came out after that yeah
tales from the dark side
I remember that's being pretty good even
that was a little budget yeah it's
conked by its own yeah yeah now there
was actually enough well I'm gonna say
an official Creepshow 3 but I'm gonna
put that in little bunny rabbit ears
because it wasn't actually official it
was a sequel in name only
what it was was some cheap Jack
production company bought the rights to
the Creepshow name and said oh I'm gonna
make an anthology horror movie and I
have not seen it although I must say
that I saw Brandon 10 olds Channel yeah
if you guys need to check that [ __ ] out
cuz he is funny as hell
yeah and he reviews he does like kind of
MNC type Rivage on just the shittiest
movies imaginable and some good ones too
he actually did one on Creepshow 3 and
from what I saw the clips I saw of it it
looks like an abomination before the
Lord I've heard it's just really really
big brand head declined yes well it
didn't have anything to do with the
other ones it was just the name there
was no one that was involved with the
first two movies had anything to do with
the third one it was just some cheap ass
thing that was trying to take advantage
of a known intellectual property but
without any of the talent involved that
happens a lot I mean yeah it's just it
looked I haven't seen the whole thing I
don't think that I wouldn't be able to
sit through the whole thing just from
the clips I've seen it but it looks
wretched it's out well the kind of sent
tales from the hood did the same thing
the first tales were supposed to be
they started to get really bad do you
know tales from the hood I think I've
got to saw the person I liked it I think
it's on shudder but maybe I don't know
if the first one or the second one or
maybe both we might have to check that
out yeah I saw I remember seeing tales
from the hood one the first one I
remember liking it yeah I remember like
it was along I don't think I saw the
second one that have it out from what I
heard like the second one was pretty
damn bad I think there's three of them
these progressively got worse I'm all
check shedder later because I'm pretty
sure I'm pretty sure at least one of the
same thing - what happened with you know
Creepshow was that you know I mean it
gets worse and worse yeah the first one
is like amazing and the second one is
decent right the third one is just
complete and utter horseshit
so I've heard and from the clips I've
said it definitely looks like and it
looks like it was just shot for like
five or something like that I mean I
love anthology movies like I said well
we'll have to do cat's eye we're gonna
do tales from the darkside details from
the hood - if it's as good as I remember
right and I also want to do some older
ones - maybe some hammer the amicus ones
that they used to do about like how it's
good candy man - so I remember well well
candy man's been on my list since the
beginning also alright cuz I [ __ ]
love that I was a good one yeah
that was easily one of the best I mean
other than how rays are easily one of
the best Clive Barker adaptations will
definitely get around it doing that
alright so like I said if you liked the
first creep show I don't see you know
the second one is obviously a big step
down but it's still like a fun time and
the third story I think is easily the
best one but they're all pretty good so
check it out if you haven't like I said
it's mostly the same people involved so
it's not like some big different thing
it was just kind of a cheaper version of
the first one so check it out if you
haven't already and that will do it for
our latest movie retrospective on
Creepshow - remember if you liked the
show like share subscribe on all your
social media if you'd like to
financially support the show you may do
so and it would be much appreciated you
can go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
and there's a PayPal button in the
sidebar go right to an account where you
can give a one-time donation
remember our movie retrospectives come
out every
Friday 13 o'clock matinee three new
movies in the theater that comes out
every Sunday and our regular episodes
come out every Tuesday and our patrons
get a day early so you get to see all
the episodes a day earlier than everyone
else does so go check that out if you
would we will see you next time bye